so
democratic senator
uh uh ostensibly democratic senator joe
manchin yesterday
gave a press conference on this spending
and infrastructure bill that he has been
uh an obstacle to actually getting
passed gave a press conference yesterday
that i can only describe to you as
kafkaesque now what what does
kafka-esque mean
fans of the tv series breaking bad might
recognize the word kafka-esque i've used
it a few times before it's really the
only word i can think of to describe
this and you'll see why in a second
kafka-esque means having a nightmarishly
complex
bizarre or illogical quality
of the example that merriam-webster
gives is that sometimes there are
kafka-esque bureaucratic delays
um
my birth country of argentina
i think is arguably best known for
kafka-esque bureaucracy problems but
that's a story for a different day i'm
gonna play some clips for you from this
joe manchin
uh press conference
in this clip i mean everything is just
backwards
joe manchin says hey listen
he's been working on this bill for three
months
and
he's urging the house to vote and pass
the bipartisan infrastructure bill take
a listen to this i've worked in good
faith for three months for the past
three months with president biden leader
schumer speaker pelosi and my colleagues
on the reconciliation bill
and i will continue to do so
for the sake of the country i urge the
house to vote and pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
joe you've been one of the primary
holdups in actually getting to a bill
that
everybody will be happy with in terms of
democrats in the senate and he now is
framing this as the fact that the house
won't vote and pass the bill he wants to
be law
means
he is no longer part of the problem
think about the backwards framing his
framing is listen when joe biden wants
to talk to me i talk to him i negotiate
with democrats i negotiate with
republicans and yet the house won't vote
on the bipartisan infrastructure bill
ignoring the fact that there's multiple
components here and multiple bills
that there is a desire to pass these in
tandem and that he has been like a
stubborn little kid that nobody can
placate who just wants attention and is
clearly enjoying the attention but he's
saying it's everybody else's fault not
mine
next clip
here he says he won't support any bill
unless he has clarity as to the impact
on inflation of that bill i for one
won't support a multi-trillion dollar
bill without greater clarity about why
congress chooses to ignore the serious
effects of inflation
and debt that have on our economy and
existing government programs these are
just the same old tired talking points
we know
uh the effect of government programs and
of government spending has he sought
clarity on it
has he spoken to economic experts about
this because these answers are available
these are not things to which we can't
find clarity and now
throwing in the typically republican
political football of our the debt the
debt the debt our debt
and then in completely you know
it's just
i don't even know what to call it
fashion
joe manchin says hey let's quit playing
games and pass the bill yeah joe you're
the one playing the games
it's time to pass the bill and quit
playing games
irony is dead
irony is dead joe manchin says let's
stop the games and pass the bill
now does he recognize the absurdity of
what he's saying and the fact that he's
the reason that
not the only reason one of the main
reasons
that we haven't yet seen a bill passed
is he the one playing games or is he
really so naive that he sees everybody
else as creating problems rather than
him
irony is dead and this is again another
reminder
uh in west virginia
you either get this or you get a
full-blown republican so the solution
isn't
to primary joe manchin
from an emotional standpoint maybe it is
maybe a lot of people would feel good
primarying joe manchin if somehow
uh uh someone to his left wins the
primary
then they lose the general
and that seat gets flipped from democrat
to republican okay maybe some people
would feel good about that because they
would feel like he lost his seat it's a
punishment to him
as we talked about with bill share and
uh and and with members of the audience
over the last couple of weeks
the real solution is you got to flip
republican seats to democrats i continue
to maintain that's the solution if you
disagree with me let me know
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries if you're
like me you're always watching
documentaries you want to find the best
ones and curiosity stream is really a
must-have curiosity stream has a better
selection of documentaries than netflix
hulu or amazon i just finished watching
wasteland about
a landfill
on the outskirts of rio in brazil
where
men and women sift through garbage
in order to try to make some money it's
horrifying but extraordinarily well done
they always have the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles when you're
looking for good documentaries use the
streaming service that specializes in
documentaries that's why i use
curiositystream they have documentaries
on politics economics history technology
psychology
everything if you love documentaries
you've got to have curiosity stream you
will see what i mean when you start
using it when you go to curiositystream
curiositystream.com pacman you'll get 25
off a subscription which comes out to
just 15 bucks a year the link is right
underneath this video